what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio fantastic Fest
20123 I'm very excited because I wanted
to talk to this guy at Tiff you were
very busy you were all over the place
dream scenario director Christopher
borley congratulations on that movie you
had an epic Premiere there and now
everybody was super into it electric
audience last night congratulations
thank you so much so I want to start at
the very beginning with this idea
there's a lot of cool Concepts B into
your movie so which specific idea would
you call your break story idea the thing
that convinced you like I have a
cohesive Vision right now and we should
move on this oh um I don't know it's
it's difficult to kind of pinpoint the
exact moment where you start believing
in in an idea uh I I feel
like the there's something undeniable
about the ideas that get like picked uh
they keep uh gnawing at you and it's
it's almost like what Carl Yung says
about uh people don't have ideas but
ideas have people uh so it feels like
this whole idea kind of uh picked me in
a way um and there's so many different
uh aspects of the the early
Inspirations um I think specifically
what was going through my mind was uh
how we live more in each other's heads
than like physically present and and uh
that we have these like parasocial
relationships with each other and
that we're you know our personas can
start taking on their own lives and
outgrow us and um those were some like
early thoughts on this I feel like I'm
jumping ahead with this question but but
given that when you started filming this
movie was there any particular idea you
were most looking forward to getting to
explore with your team and your actors
but then on the other hand is there a
particular element of this story that
wound up being more creatively
fulfilling for you than you ever could
have imagined at the beginning o I mean
um yeah this might be a spoiler I don't
know but if you say anything that's
spoiler uh spoilery we could put a
little uh warning and save it for later
okay but there's I I'll say this there's
a um an attempted sex scene in the
middle of the movie that was kind I
think that was one of the very first
ideas and there's something there
about your
perceived idea of someone versus the
reality of someone that comes to an
embarrassing kind of uh manifestation in
that scene that is one of the best fart
jokes I've ever seen in a movie like how
how do you shoot a scene like that and
have everybody not break keep a straight
face not laugh um it was um I mean I
just had to place my monitor in a
different room I couldn't be in the room
I would I ruined the takes by laughing
so uh the actors did their thing uh and
and and managed to you know get through
it um it
was not only a cringe inducing scene to
uh write and direct but even when I was
editing that scene I had to leave
multiple times my editing desk and just
like I couldn't be in the same room as
my computer it was just so cringy to
watch but I will say with that
particular scene I've seen it twice now
I've seen it at Tiff and here I knew
that moment was coming and even though I
knew oh bad choice of words there but
even though I knew that F joke was going
to happen I still like cackled
uncontrollably in this reading yeah I
mean it's um it's an UNS subtle very
banale moment that I think has uh its
place in in like an artistic movie
there's a there's um a little history of
of movies that I remember having like
memorable uh fart jokes that kind of
feel a little bit out of place one is uh
35 rums the CLA Dene movie okay there's
a really good one in there and uh the
master Paul Thomas Anderson has also
like a really never thought I would need
a list of like the best fart jokes in
movies but now now you're making my mind
yeah in artistic kind of um I don't know
you had mentioned that there was a point
where you might have had Adam Sandler
play the Nick Cage role in this film and
watching the finished film that role
feels so specific to Nick so I am
wondering when you were thinking about
having Adam play that character what did
that film look like and how did the idea
evolve when Nick took the role over yeah
um I think that uh like looking back in
retrospect uh it's it's impossible for
me to uh unsee Nick in this part um he
just
um made the character so watchable and
interesting he does so many choices that
are kind of like mesmerizing and and
strange in a good way and um not only is
he such a good actor but just the idea
of Nicholas Cage in our culture who has
gone through the thing where your
persona outgrows the
person um and so he added kind of like a
an artistic layer to the movie that is
also hugely interesting and I think he
channeled some of his own um personal
experiences through the character and
there's some truth in that there's some
autobiographical elements of Nicholas
Cage and in this role I do have a pitch
for you though cuz I think it would be a
very interesting experiment you should
turn dream scenario into an anthology
series and have the main role played by
different actors at like different
stages of their career just to see how
the concept would evolve from person to
person okay there's some money to be
made here I think 824 you can have that
idea I just want to see more of this uh
one other thing I was reading about is
the the choice to alter Nick Cage's nose
in the movie how exactly do you alter it
and what led you to to decide that that
was best for the character of Paul we
were going to have one of the most
recognizable and charismatic actors on
the planet uh play like a nobody an
uninteresting kind of un you know
unremarkable person uh we had to kind of
hide Nicholas Cage in the role um and I
got help from Izzy Galindo a Prosthetics
designer who did my previous movie sick
of
myself uh and we toyed with different
ideas of how to like slightly alter his
face without it being
noticeable um and he is wearing a
prosthetic nose in the in the film and
it makes him like
slightly more round and slightly more of
a beta mail very very very effective and
like you said it is not something that
kind of sticks out immediately which
which makes it an especially uh an
especially effective prosthetic yeah
there's like some strange uncanniness
where it is Nicholas Cage but he's so
different that at least me like I forget
that it's him like I just see Paul
Matthews the character yeah very much so
so one other thing that he had mentioned
in our press notes I think he described
your collaboration as him giving you
full control so I am curious what is
that like and how does your
collaboration with an actor who gives
you full control compared to someone who
who maybe does doesn't or just
approaches the collaboration process in
a different way yeah I think like he's
he's almost exaggerating a little bit I
mean he he there was a lot of the
choices that was not made by me that he
he made his own decisions and um he had
a bunch of ideas of of different scenes
of mannerisms of of the way he talks and
walks and he was full of ideas he was so
well prepared he was a great collab at I
think we kind of uh sculpted this
performance together I think one of the
things that he was emphasizing via that
point was how important it was to like
put the trust in the leader in order for
this wild idea to come together and I I
respect that quite a bit I feel like you
have to do that with something like this
yeah yeah and and yeah hats off to him
like this this uh it it's still baffling
to me that that you know that I've made
a movie with with Nicholas Cage Nick
Cage and like a slew of other incredible
actors too you got one heck of an
ensemble here it is it is I'm so uh
grateful for the whole cast there's you
know not a dull moment in this movie
they're all so great yeah can confirm
that all right I'm going to preface
these next questions by saying you do
not need to explain everything away in
terms of how the dreams work in this
movie I tend to be a like a lore Bible
and Rule nerd though so I did have a
couple of questions just in your own
personal opinion
why do you think this happened to Paul
and nobody else on the
planet so there's I
mean I was uh when writing this I was
looking for the person who I thought
would be um comedically interesting to
throw into this
phenomenon and I thought of this kind of
antiquated man who doesn't fully
understand our current
culture who uh feels cheated of U
academic
recognition would uh respond to this in
all the wrong ways and and that's why it
became him here's another one do you
think that Paul's actions in the real
world truly do influence how he is
perceived in dreams that's my
understanding that's uh there's this uh
Union concept of the Shadow Self uh and
the idea uh being uh that all of our
kind of negative traits that we do not
confront starts bundling up and and
manifests itself maybe in the
subconscious um and that uh they could
start showing up in your dreams um and
the idea here was that his uh um you
know negative qualities or insecurities
were so strong that they started showing
up in other people's dreams in your
world here do you think that the
individual having the dream can impact
how they perceive Paul in it in
particular I'm thinking of Molly and the
fact that she seems if she's even
telling the truth which she might not be
if she is having a different dream
because of things about her versus
everybody else right um maybe there's
something about the confidence level
that Paul Matthews starts having uh when
he gets wed
recognized that inflates his ego and
maybe that's the version of him that she
meets in her dreams I can think about
this concept all day long having made
this movie yourself this is a bit of a
personal question but having thought
about these ideas and doing some dream
research yourself have you found the
experience impacting your own dreams or
maybe how you process them exactly yeah
I I keep a a dream journal uh it's you
know a fun read it's strange I can't
really I don't think I
fully believe in the yion or the like
Freudian idea that they do reveal our
deepest Secrets I think they're more
random than that I or at least I hope so
cuz my dreams are like um you know
strange and and weird and I hope they
don't hold a secret truth about who I
really am
um and and uh my own dreams became a
point of you know research and and a
resource for for writing these uh dreams
so there's a bunch of my personal kind
of strange uh dreams recurring dreams
that are depicted in this movie can you
give us an example well it's the a
specific thing that I think a lot of
people have is the feeling of being in a
fight and your arms are like moving so
slow that they have zero
impact uh and you see that in the film
um and then like being chased and never
being able to escape whoever is chasing
you that's also something that you see
in the movie uh those are my most
recurring dreams were there any dream
scenarios you either came up with in the
script phase or even shot and did not
make it into the Final Cut of the movie
yeah there's one dream um there's one
dream sequence that didn't make it to
the cut because it was too iic for the
moment in the film are you able to
should I should I press for more are you
able to share what that was it was a a a
naked woman who was taped very high up
on a wall and there was also French
baguettes taped a wall and it was one of
the French
dreams